now the left pretends to be the party of
women they say push out messages like
believe all women
they talk about girl power and who can
forget Hillary's slogan back in 2016 I'm
with her
but they're not really with women they
can't even Define what a woman is in
fact
they're totally stumped by the question
can you provide a definition for the
word woman can I provide a definition no
I'm not a biology can you please define
for me what is a woman our focus at the
department is to provide equal access to
students including students who are
lgbtq
we want a specific definition of what a
woman is you want a legal definition
well for them Dylan Mulvaney and the men
featured in The Sports Illustrated issue
swimsuit issue well they epitomize what
modern Womanhood should be
but in the end really this is all
political because if you don't agree
with them on every issue a key left-wing
issue then they're not with you and
they're never going to celebrate you
consider what Politico just wrote about
Ron desantis's wife Casey this was just
days of course before he's expected to
enter the presidential race
they write she's neither the fawning
caricature she's made out to be nor a
Shakespearean villain she might well be
a bit of both
she can also accentuate even exacerbate
her husband's hubris and his paranoia
and his vaulting ambition
because those are all traits that they
share
wait wait wait
whoa wait what happened to all that girl
power you know she's a mom she's a
cancer survivor
she's a you know former you know female
professional in the media business
they must have used all their
celebratory language up on Jill Biden
a couple of headlines over the years
about Jill the same publication by the
way that just trash Casey DeSantis Jill
Biden the ultra ultimate Secret Santa
Jill Biden untraditional Unapologetic
how Jill Biden helped Joe get to yes on
running for re-election at 80. she is
the not so secret weapon behind her
husband
ah and if that didn't take you to the
vomitorium here's more
Joe Biden's number one advisor and
cheerleader his wife Jill Biden
President Biden's closest advisor and
Confidant not just the first lady but a
close friend and advisor Dr Biden the
The Hope Ambassador if you will
oh that's right Dr Biden always remember
the doctor
I wonder why Casey DeSantis didn't get
that same treatment or even Melania
Trump they hated Melania
the left doesn't support women they
never will they support women who tow
the liberal line
and if you stray if you're truly an
independent thinker
you're going to have your female card
revoked
and they'll probably just toss it over
to Mulvaney
all right before we go a little update
on the story we brought you this week
about homeless vets being displaced from
hotels so that illegals could move in
turns out the group behind the claim
made it up
we have no clue as to why anyone would
do such a thing but we'll bring you any
updates should they come hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else